he's the we think retired Olympic
swimmer Michael Phelps joining us we'll
get into that topic here in a moment
over the last three years Michael has
been working with Colgate as their
global ambassador to raise awareness
about water waste and making a global
impact on water conservation we'll talk
about that coming up in a moment I'm
just riding this subway today and I saw
your picture all over the subway I mean
I'm a man of the people I don't know the
last time you've been on the subway
there Michael
I've never actually been on the subway
and every single person sends me I think
the photo of talk space that you're
talking about and I still have yet to
see an advertisement in New York City
why are you afraid to ride this subway
no I just I think I've just never I
don't know I've had the opportunity or I
don't know what you do sue right next to
your picture yeah it might be
interesting to see the looks and the
reactions I get I had a lot of different
thoughts walking in today well taking
the subway in today and I was wondering
do you keep the bronze and silver with
the gold medals or do you keep the gold
separate I don't even talk about the
bronze and silver I try to forget those
as much as I can because it's I mean for
me are they negative well I I guess I
look at it as I could have done better
so it's it's frustrating for me I always
am very hard on myself so if I was
second or third then I don't think I did
everything that I probably could have to
prepare what's worth second or fourth
fourth fourth okay not on the podium is
you gotta at least get some hardware
when's the last time you weren't on the
podium London wanted I am or actually
was fourth yeah and in that a weird
thing where you where everybody gets
together for medals and then all of a
sudden when I'm supposed to be up there
that was a that was a race that I've
forgotten so thanks for inviting me
I forget about all those and and London
was an Olympics that I was not very
happy with if you could exchange your
Olympic career for another Olympian
whose if you had to just for fun and you
said okay I can't have my career but I
can have that career I don't want to
know but if you could who would you it's
just a game Mike ah I've never thought
about it though so I mean hasn't even
know like Usain Bolt's or I mean I guess
if I if I had to pick any matter I'd I
think I'd probably want to be a golfer
because that was the one sport that I
wanted to be really and I still want to
be really good at yeah so I think that's
what I would pick out I don't I don't
know though like specifically what other
Olympians so if you could take Tigers
career over your career yeah it'd be
kind of fun why not have you go off with
him I haven't I don't think he wants to
see anything that I have on the golfers
how would you rate how would you rate
your golf game I'm actually it's okay
I'm awful at chipping I've awful hands
so me around the green is not pretty
I've zero confidence with a 60 or 55 in
my hands so you know no touch when you
when you start to think about your
career I think the last time you run you
said I haven't been able to kind of put
it all together all the pieces and
figure out exactly what I accomplished
are we far enough away from that where
you can now look back and say I mean I
think I understand a little bit of what
I've accomplished
I honestly think I'm understanding the
process more than anything else right
now watching a couple friends go through
you know the getting ready to get ready
for the next Olympics
trying to help them get through certain
obstacles I think I have a better
understanding of what I did in 16 and
what I did leading up to that point to
allow me to have the career that I did
but what are the obstacles like like
mental challenges that you have you know
there are days obviously you're tired
you're beaten down and you know you
really think you can't do it and that's
really where you have to kind of dig
into your mental side and
figure a way to get it done what was
your relationship like with the pool
when you were swimming everyday training
every day it was kind of like home to me
you know honestly like I have a friend
that jokes all the time and he's like
you're Aquaman like you're literally
Aquaman okay I mean I spent more time in
water than I have on land really so to
say right like I you know I I don't mind
never walk that much during my career so
I'm now finding out what walking feels
like so that's interesting but yes I
mean I think that's that's been the
coolest thing for me just it's kind of
seeing the process and and I actually
started showing booms a couple more
races this is your my ocean
my oldest son boomer and and he enjoys
watching the races and I think he enjoys
the pool more than back it does right
now so maybe he's got a career in it
we'll see are you pushing him too no no
no I will not I won't I mean I think the
biggest thing is I want him to just be
able to find who he is and find what
he's passionate about I mean I was never
super pushed as a kid my mom was just
kind of let me do what I wanted to do I
think that was one of the reasons why I
was able to have the longevity that I
had yeah I didn't know if it's a
love-hate relationship because I've
spoken to other swimmers where you get
to that pool when you just look at that
pool when you hate that pool but you
know you need that pool I think I'm
actually to that point now I sense
retiring I always said that I never
wanted to be in the pool I wanted to
spend as much time away from this I
possibly could and it's actually the
direct opposite now it's almost like a
therapy session for me being able to go
into the pool and and have that peace
and quiet where I don't have you know
questions I don't have screaming all
these noises it's just me in the pool
and I'm out I can just be in my own head
and kind of get done what I need to get
done so I think for me it's just an
outlet that that helps me be the best me
that I can be do you ever get you know
like MMA guys get somebody wants to
challenge them or basketball players
somebody sees you on the playground you
get some dopey guy who wants to
challenge you in the pool every now and
you'll get a guy at at the country club
that might push off the same time as you
and you're like guys just stop just stop
it's it is comical though and and I'll
have people asking like how I do certain
things and and I I try to be as nice as
I can but it's it is it's it's
challenging we were look we're talking
to Michael Phelps here in the man cave
we were looking at the picture again
where you beat cabbage yeah and we were
wondering that maybe like the the
website Funny or Die could do a great
bit with you guys where no matter what
you do let's say there's a parking spot
you get in right before he does or
there's two beers on the bar and then
you babble here before he does and so
it's right at the last second second do
you think that he would have a sense of
humor to do that I I don't know I
haven't seen in my life
be kind of funny sure is iconic I in my
office I have that photo framed and and
it's it's crazy to think back of there's
think think back to excuse me I mean
looking at that touch 1/100 is it's
mind-blowing and honestly it's but where
are your arms are right before that it's
like how did you get from there to there
it it was just the judging of all I mean
that was really all it was and as a kid
growing up that was something that Bob
always just kind of forced us to do
judging every single wall hitting every
single turn it was just an instinct to
that point and you were behind on the
turn yeah I'm always behind so did you
not not anything there did you start to
like are you thinking at all when you
swim no not really I mean I have an
understanding of where people are in the
race and I have an understanding of
where I need to be at certain points to
win the race and on that one I knew I
had to be 2400 or better at the first 50
and I think I was 24:01 so at that point
we just knew that it's a numbers game
like he can't if he if kavik was out
that fast he wasn't gonna be able to
finish as fast as I could so I just had
to be at the right place the right time
kind of Ricky
Bobby it a little bit what's the
strangest thing you ever thought about
while you're racing I don't really think
about anything nothing no I dive in the
water and that's a because I mean you
can't think of anything else that really
at that point but a long race you can't
you don't I'm never in the water for
more minutes
well okay and I'm in a lot of pain
during that race sorry really
yeah the forum is brutal it's the
hardest do you miss that pain nope not
one bit because a lot of guys love the
boxers love the pain part of it but you
know no interest whatsoever I'm good
let's recap the bet that we had a couple
years ago
Paulie wanted he said he thinks that
you're gonna be swimming in the 2020
games right now
you look race-ready but yeah you do men
shape yeah yeah I'm sure but but there
is let's make it official official
you're not racing in the twenty okay so
if I was racing in the 2020 games then
that would mean that I would have to be
into the drug testing pool by this point
right because I have to make Olympic
Trials all that process the nine-month
window I'm not in the testing pool right
now so right now right now thanks it's
less than a year away and there's not
enough time I could get those so we
might have to put you in a brief or
unless you have one on today well you
don't wear speedos yes we don't say that
word don't stay speedos when did we when
do we get rid of speedos I've been with
them for a while yeah but you have your
own brand correct yes MP yeah yes
because that's kind of like q-tip right
it's really cold like a cotton swab but
it's like a brand right right right yeah
there are other names for it but it's
some of them probably uh appropriate for
you guys can do some research online I'm
sure you can figure out a couple good
ones like nut smugglers yeah that's a
good
alright Dan six years ago we did the
show Michael and you said you weren't
gonna race in 2016 I thought you would I
thought there's a lot of good things
financially for your family and I
thought when you had your first son and
seeing your son at the rate all the
races in 16 we've had a lot of athletes
on the show like Jeff Gordon Peyton
Manning and they want their kids to see
them perform at their best you have
three sons now I got one this is one
lettuce in it I won't be in 2020 I
guarantee that and and I don't have any
plans of coming back any time there you
go Paulie so you have to get so again he
said not in 2020 but when he said that I
said I said I have no plans to do
anything else so I believe the bet was
for 2020 right right yeah okay so I'm
not swimming as soon as the Olympics
Paulie you lost me I'm not lost the bet
yeah how about a slingshot instead of a
brief what is that but I have a picture
of Michael and myself side by side up on
the screen so you can see what we're
looking at here all right and there's
Mike you're in pretty good shape on this
one you're in you're Michael Phelps what
do you call it the pose reef yeah Bri
briefed
oh I'm not for a jammer I'm not what you
call good shape how am I gonna look in
that thing in the in the jammer we got a
couple months better get ready I need
for season coming up so my wife said she
thought you had an extra AB like a
little half one I think I said that she
was looking a little too close from me
but L okay so Michael's on the right is
yeah I had to explain that that's Paulie
on the left having a beer yeah similar
body types yeah I own a pool I don't
never swim I want to have you talk about
what you're doing with Colgate and then
I have a gift for you awesome yeah
so go ahead fire away without doing so
for me this is this is our third year
and and you know for me now growing to a
family of five it's something that's
super important for me water is
something that's been a massive part of
my life and and I want it to be a big
part of my life for for the rest of my
life and everybody needs to have that
chance and it's such a resource that
we're wasting so much of you know so
turning your faucet off when you're
brushing your teeth can save sixty four
glasses of water and
we've started this campaign in the last
three years we've actually been able to
save
we're working on the final number but
I've heard it's over fifty billion
gallons and and if you think about it
imagine a day without water can't brush
your teeth can't rinse your toothbrush
can't make a cup of coffee can't take a
shower can't wash clothes can't wash
dishes so this is something that we need
forever and something that we all need
to jump on board even more than we
already are to save as much as we can
how'd you get involved in this waters
always I mean like I said waters just
been important to me forever
yeah and it's it's always gonna be a
part of my life and and it's something
that you know I mean turning the water
on and off where you're brushing your
teeth for me it's just something that's
common sense right you just don't want
to listen and you don't wanna waste all
that water no you know it's it's just
something that we've taught our kids and
and with how the world is today and and
all of the things that we can do to make
it a better place in the future this is
something that's a huge passion for me
and something I'm honored that I'm able
to do this is there a website for people
to get more information
pop on Colgate and and you can look at
all that stuff I mean this is stuff that
we've like I said been doing for three
years and we need more help I have I
have a gift last time Michael was on he
talked about getting snubbed by a
baseball player oh gosh and the player
was Bob Milwaukee and this is what
Michael said when he was talking about
as a youngster the pitcher Bob Milwaukee
did not give Michael Phelps an autograph
I was getting autographs memorials and a
bunch of them snubbed me I was kind of
bummed about that how old up there
I must have been seven years old I mean
there's one picture in particular I'll
never forget I know exactly his name but
I probably won't say he played for the
Orioles in the late 90s and I wanted to
thought it got so bad it's nothing and
that that stuck with me my whole life I
don't even know you remember the name
Bob Milwaukee yeah yep you mentioned Bob
Milwaukee I think I actually when I said
that I was there Ben McDonald was on the
team as well yeah and his wife
if randomly reached out to me on social
media and commented about it and I was
just dying laughing it was just chaos
hysterical now I have a bottle a key
baseball Bob Milwaukee baseball I got
cards - cards a letter oh my gosh
and a Bob Milwaukee Jersey one of one
this is this is with the Nationals when
he and he signed it to Michael the
greatest Olympian of all time best
regards Bob malarkey that is priceless
that is amazing there you go thank you I
wanted to make up for the worst day of
your life it may be the greatest day of
your life
you got your autograph from Bimal a key
thank you it's great to see you
good luck with the boys think and stay
out of the water at least in the 2025
that's that's that's a fact it's gonna
be in a swimsuit
pretty dang soon for more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]